so whenever you define a recursive
datatype the part of the implicit in the
definition is a method for proving
things about it called structural
induction and the way structural
induction works is that if you want to
prove that every element in some
recursively defined data type has a
particular property P then you proceed
by showing that every one of the
elements in the base case that are in R
has property P and moreover that if you
apply a constructor to an element X then
it has property P whenever X has
property pay that as you can assume as
an as a structural induction hypothesis
P of X and then you need to show that P
of C of X holds in the supplies for each
constructor see some constructors take
more than one arguments but this is
meant to illustrate the general pattern
let's do an easy example first this is
when we've actually seen and we took for
granted this method of proof without
highlighting it when we argued that the
set e that was recursively defined in
the last presentation contained the even
only even numbers so remember the
definition of E was that zero is in E
and we're going to be proving that X is
even by induction so we need to check
the base case yes zero is even and then
we need to show that assuming the
structural induction hypothesis that n
is even then when we apply the
constructor n plus two it's even well
obviously it is or if we constructor
minus n that's also even and it is as
well and that's why structural induction
tells us that in fact every string in
the set E is even now let's look at a
somewhat more example interesting
example which was the set M of matching
right and left brackets and what I want
to prove by structural induction is that
every string in M has the same number of
left brackets and
brackets all right
I can restate this by defining EQ to be
the set of strings with the same number
of right and left brackets and what I'm
really trying to say is that M is a
subset of EQ all right now the way I'm
gonna prove this is by defining my
induction hypothesis P of s to be that s
is an EQ that is s has an equal number
of left and right brackets well let's
remember what the definition of M was
the base case of M was the empty string
with no brackets at all and does the
empty string satisfy P of s well yeah it
has zero right brackets and 0 left
brackets so it does have an equal number
of left and right brackets so we've
established that the base case P of and
of the empty string is true ok now we
have to consider the constructor case in
the case of M there's only one
constructor namely if R and T are in M
then so is s which you get by putting
brackets around R and following it by T
well here's the argument we're allowed
to assume when we're trying to prove
that s has an equal number of left and
right brackets and we're allowed to
assume that R does and so does T so
let's look at the number of right
brackets in s well where do they come
from the right brackets in S consists of
well the first symbol in S is a left
bracket so that doesn't matter then it's
the right brackets in R and then there
is a new right bracket that gets added
and then there are the right brackets in
T so what I can say is that the left
bracket the right brackets in S are
simply the number of them is the sum of
the number in R plus the number and T
plus 1 more because the constructor
threw in one more right bracket by
exactly the same reasoning the number of
left brackets in s is the number of left
in are left in T plus 1 now because of
hypothesis P of R
the number of right and left brackets in
our are equal and likewise by the
induction hypothesis P of T the number
of right and left brackets in T are
equal and so the right-hand sides of
both of these equations are equal and
that means that the left-hand sides are
equal
we've just proved that the number of
right brackets in s in the number of
left brackets in s are the same so P of
S is true the constructor case is
covered and we can conclude by
structural induction that every s in the
set M recursively defined set of strings
of match brackets is in fact has an
equal number of left and right brackets
which means that M is a subset of Q as
claimed well those are pretty easy
structural inductions and as with
regular induction proofs when you get
the right induction hypothesis the
proofs tend to be easy and we are going
to work on an interesting example having
to do with the f18 functions one of the
reasons why the f-18s are what's
considered in first term calculus is
that if you look at all of those
functions remember you got them by
taking constant functions and the
identity function and function sine X
and then you could combine them in
various ways by adding multiplying
exponentiating composing thinking
inverses that we didn't need to add a
constructor of taking the derivative
because it turns out that you can prove
by structural induction that the FA
teens are closed under taking
derivatives and that makes a lovely
class problem